There is a fundamental anthropologic
will need for physical shopping.
So I don't think the high street is
going anywhere anytime soon,
but I think shopping has evolved over
the years and it will continue to
evolve.
Technology does represent,
I think a chance for a fundamental
change in the nature of the high street.
We all seen dramatic change in high
streets in town centers.
That means they are never ever going to
be the way they,
that will always be the bookies and the
charity shops,
um,
under greg's on high street.
But I think,
yeah,
most of us that have that traditional
retailers will migrate online.
We're definitely not saying that.
I think the high street,
I don't think anyway,
I think there's a place to have online
shopping and the high street for
anything,
electronics or something like that.
I'll buy it online,
but for some things,
maybe not just makeup and perfume and
that kind of thing.
Again,
I think you want to go and see if it
works with your skin or that kind of
side of things.
For me,
it's the convenience of being at my
house or my office and seeing literally
everything at the world available for me
to look up to.
Many of these debates are around the
idea of the high street as this really
nostalgic view of the single
thoroughfare that families would go to
on a Saturday afternoon and do all of
that shopping and that genuinely doesn't
reflect the state of the world.
I think it depends what you mean by the
high streets.
I mean a physical straight down the
middle of a town potentially is under
massive threat,
but physical retail,
I don't think we're going to see the
test of it at all and also in that role
still be in the middle of town.
I think you've raised some really
interesting points and now jump up
farther and do further research or no,
I thought it was a really good opening
to the discussion.
It was very interesting.
It's very controversial at times.
I thought more boring for discussion and
divide.
It got me thinking with you about a few
other things that I thought were maybe
not employed right now or not.
Kind of talk,
talk to me about,
and we're thinking about Ebay is a,
as a store I think is,
you know,
is,
um,
you know,
good as a,
uh,
as an online entity in itself,
but also works well with offline.
Some of the offerings that we have,
like our relationship with our gos,
which reinforces the High Street and
gives people an extra option that,
uh,
kind of positively influences the,
um,
uh,
the high street.
So I,
I think the high street is just in a
period of rebirth rather than,
uh,
rather than any demise.